mehr ladestationen für e autos die
bundesregierung will den ausbau
vorantreiben auch dort wo es
wirtschaftlich unattraktiv ist
hoffnung auf grundlegende reformen in
chile haben wieder zehntausende
friedlich demonstriert es gab aber auch
gewalt keine entwarnung in sicht in
kalifornien ist ein weiteres feuer
ausgebrochen rund um los angeles geht
immer noch warnstufe rot
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem samstag
an meiner seite ist für den sport
norbert lehmann mit der fußball
bundesliga eine schöne genannter von mir
wenn deutschland seine klimaziele
erreichen will dann braucht es in den
kommenden jahren millionen von
elektroautos bislang sind allerdings
gerade mal 220.000 zugelassen
viele kaufen auch deshalb keinesfalls zu
wenige ladestationen gibt das will die
bundesregierung jetzt ändern mit einem
masterplan ladeinfrastruktur christiane
hübscher schon bald soll eine solche
wall box also eine ladebox für die wand
in vielen deutschen privat garagen
hängen
es gibt sie ab 500 euro und die
bundesregierung will künftig jedem
käufer geld dazugeben so jedenfalls
verspricht es der sogenannte masterplan
ladeinfrastruktur an dem der
verkehrsminister seit monaten arbeitet
da geht es aber auch darum politische
rahmenbedingungen zu setzen von der
steuergesetzgebung bis zum
wohnungseigentum stichwort ladesäulen in
tiefgaragen von mehrfamilienhäusern geht
es nach scheuer müssen vermieter ihren
mietern künftig den einbau einer
privaten ladestation erlauben denn das
zuhause laden können sei ein wichtiger
hebel für die kaufentscheidung hat die
bundesregierung erkannt
reichlich spät meint die opposition die
erkenntnis dass man da mehr tun muss
die ist gut aber die kommt zu spät wir
haben internationalen stück weit den
anschluss verloren
deutschland hinkt auch hinter anderen
europäischen ländern hinterher
das problem ist dass es kein
geschäftsmodell gibt bei denen lade
sollen die einen rechnen nach zeit ab
die andere nach kilowattstunde
und das ist auch eines der kernprobleme
wer das ganze wie betreiben soll im
öffentlichen raum werden fürs erste laut
entwurf an allen bundesautobahnen und
bundesfernstraßen 1000 neue schnell
ladepunkte gefördert bis 2030 sollen es
dann überall in stadt und land eine
million öffentliche ladepunkte sein
die energiewirtschaft soll jetzt
möglichst schnell den bagger herausholen
und sich auch um eine einfache
abwicklung der bezahlung des strom
tanken zu kümmern
die energieunternehmen sind
grundsätzlich zu investitionen bereit
vom
co-autor land deutschland aber noch
nicht völlig überzeugt die leute die die
lade infrastruktur bereitstellen sollen
müssen auch in der lage sein dass
irgendwo finanziell abzubilden heißt für
mich im klartext so wie es die
ladeinfrastruktur braucht braucht es die
fahrzeuge die sie auch nutzen in einer
auskömmlichen zahl das henne-ei-problem
die bundesregierung hofft bis 2030 auf 7
bis 10 millionen elektroautos in
deutschland
der verkehrsminister wird seinen plan am
montag im kanzleramt mit merkel und den
chefs der automobilindustrie diskutieren
auch wegen des klimaschutzes steigen die
subventionen im nächsten jahr offenbar
auf einen rekordwert von gut 31
milliarden euro berichtet die bild
-zeitung hauptursache wie geplanten
fördermaßnahmen der bundesregierung
das finanzministerium wollte dies nicht
kommentieren
das rennen um den parteivorsitz der spd
geht weiter nachdem bei der ersten wahl
keines der kandidatenpaare die absolute
mehrheit bekommen hat müssen die zwei
verbleibenden duos jetzt wieder auf
stimmenfang gehen für die stichwahl ende
november
dabei geht es auch um die künftige
ausrichtung der spd-finanzminister
scholz und seine partnerin klara geywitz
gelten als befürworter der großen
koalition
saskia esken und norbert walter borjans
er als kritiker christoph distel mit
einem stimmungsbild von der basis
baunatal in nordhessen landesparteitag
der spd
es geht um landes personalien eigentlich
doch die andere die große personalie
schwebt mit im raum wer rettet die
bundes-spd dass er weiter so du oder
dass er groß skeptische du so richtig
festlegen will sich keiner
aber was jetzt zähle sei vor allem die
partei sagen alle
wer bei der wahl meint dass es um die
coco nur geht und nicht um inhaltliche
auseinandersetzungen wie wir uns als spd
die zukunft vorstellen er hat glaube das
nicht verstanden und deswegen es geht
nicht um die gruppo sondern wenn diese
partei leiten sollen
seit einer woche ist klar scholz
gallwitz oder walter borjans esken eines
dieser paare wird die spd übernehmen und
kleine überraschung ausgerechnet der ex
vorsitzende schulz empfiehlt einen
früheren widersacher der sei nämlich
besser vernetzt deshalb komme ich zu dem
schluss dass sich bei allen differenzen
olaf scholz mehr vertrauen als den
anderen bewerbern und ich kann sagen
leicht fällt mir dieser schritt nicht
hamburg noch ein spd-landesparteitag
fast alle im saal sind für den aus ihren
reihen
mein favoritenteam ist das team klara
geywitz olaf scholz und es liegt
wirklich daran dass ich insbesondere
olaf scholz seit 20 jahren kenne und
weiß was er einbringen kann und
entsprechend sind die gegen halbe sachen
bei der großen koalition auf landesebene
gab sich die partei heute geschlossen
ganz klare ergebnisse für ihre
führungsleute nancy faeser in hessen und
peter tschentscher in hamburg so viel
einigkeit wünschen sie sich auch von der
bundes spd und wissen doch das wird
nicht leicht
die ehemaligen grünen chefs cem özdemir
und claudia roth stehen auf einer
todesliste von rechtsextremisten
zeitungen der funke mediengruppe
berichten von einem schreiben einer
radikalen gruppe mit wurzeln in den usa
die dort als extrem gewaltbereit gilt
der müsste mir erhält bereits
personenschutz weil er wegen seiner
kritik am türkischen präsidenten erdogan
bedroht wird claudia roth ließ wissen
sie wolle sich auch weiter für eine
vielfältige und weltoffene gesellschaft
einsetzen
in chile gehen weiter zehntausende auf
die straßen darunter viele junge
menschen und familien
auslöser war eine fahrpreiserhöhung für
die metro in der hauptstadt die hat
präsident pinera zwar inzwischen
zurückgenommen
doch die proteste halten an sie richten
sich gegen die soziale ungleichheit in
einem der reichsten länder
lateinamerikas christoph volkert
berichtet von einer großdemo die
friedlich begann und dann doch in gewalt
umschlug
sie marschieren mit verbundenen augen
solidarität mit jenen die durch
gummigeschosse der polizei ihr
augenlicht verloren haben
von dutzenden fällen ist die rede
insgesamt wurden bislang mehr als 1300
demonstranten verletzt
mindestens 20 kamen bei den protesten in
chile ums leben wir sind hier für die
toten die ermordeten für die die auf
eine demo ging und nicht wieder nach
hause zurückkehren
seit wochen gehen die menschen auf die
strassen demonstrieren gegen hohe
lebenshaltungskosten niedrige löhne und
renten gegen wachsende soziale
ungleichheit
wir wollen unsere würde zurück unsere
demokratie stirbt weil sie dem
neoliberalismus geopfert wird
die menschen verlieren ihre freiheit ich
bin hier für meine tochter für die neue
generation
es lebe chile und alle chilene immer
wieder kommt es zu gewalt von beiden
seiten wenige augenblicke nachdem wir
diese bilder gedreht haben wendet sich
die aggression direkt gegen uns
irgendwer ruft wir seien die lügen die
chilenische presse der regierung
schlagartig werden wir brutal
angegriffen müssen flüchten
wir sind gerade von einer immer größer
werdenden gruppe von demonstranten
massiv angegriffen wurden wir wurden
geschlagen
unsere ausrüstung wurde beschädigt man
wollte uns die kamera weg reißen und wir
mussten tatsächlich rennen steine flogen
hinter uns her es wurde mit
steinschleudern auf uns geschossen
wir hatten ein riesenglück und erst als
wir hier bei diesen fahrzeugen
angekommen sind hat der mob hat diese
wütender masse von uns abgelassen ist
zeigt wie aggressiv die stimmung
inzwischen ist selbst der presse
gegenüber die spuren an den
panzerfahrzeugen der polizei sprechen
eine eigene sprache die wut geht weiter
um in chile brandgefährliche lage
christoph röck hat woher kommt diese wut
und warum entlädt sie sich gerade jetzt
ich denke dass viele menschen ein großes
gefühl der ohnmacht empfinden dass sie
sich von ihrem eigenen staat
regelrecht betrogen fühlen und ein grund
treppe ist eben dass chile sehr früh
stärker als andere staaten auf den
freien markt und auf privatisierung
gesetzt hat das hat zum einen dazu
geführt dass es hier ein starkes
wachstum gibt man sieht es hier überall
um uns herum
santiago ist eine sehr moderne stadt
aber es führt eben auch dazu dass die
schere zwischen arm und reich viel
stärker auseinander gegangen ist als man
erwartet hat und vor allem als die
gesellschaft anscheinend vertragen kann
viele junge leute fühlen sich mehrere
perspektiven betrogen weil die linien
löhne niedrig sind viele alte leute um
ihre lebensleistung weil die renten
ebenfalls zu niedrig sind und das führt
eben zu dieser wut das interessante ist
das ist nicht etwa ein anführer dafür
gibt oder eine partei die das ganze
vorantreibt sondern es geht quer durch
die gesellschaft und das macht es auch
so schwer für die regierung damit
einzelnen maßnahmen gegenzusteuern
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
danken nach chile christopher karat und
wir bitten die krise lichkeit in dem
bild zu entschuldigen
das deutsche rettungsschiff alanco die
darf im hafen der süditalienischen stadt
tarent anlegen das hat das
innenministerium in rom entschieden
nach gut einer woche auf dem mittelmeer
war die crew nach eigenen angaben wegen
schlechten wetters in italienische
hoheitsgewässer eingefahren
deutschland und frankreich haben sich
bereit erklärt insgesamt 60 der 88
migranten aufzunehmen
seit juni protestieren sie jedes
wochenende trotz verboten gewalt und
schikanen seit nunmehr 22 wochen sind
die demonstranten in hongkong immer
wieder auf der straße
es geht nicht mehr nur um freie wahlen
mittlerweile fordern sie auch eine
unabhängige untersuchung der
polizeibrutalität und straffreiheit für
die mehr als 2000 festgenommenen
stefanie schöneborn berichtet
lokalwahlen stehen an in hongkong am 24
november
dafür sind sie heute zum victoria park
gekommen wahlkampfauftritt ganz
offiziell und legal doch auch heute geht
es um mehr
wir bleiben bei unseren forderungen der
letzten wochen alle sollen erfüllt
werden keine weniger bei dieser
friedlichen kundgebung heute sollte die
polizei kein tränengas einsetzten
selbst die politisch eigentlich wenig
bedeutsam lokalwahlen sind in hongkong
dieser tage hoch politisch der wahlkampf
auftritt wird zur kundgebung zum
protestmarsch richtet sich vor allem
gegen die von regierung und gegen china
wir werden nicht aufhören auf die straße
zu gehen bis die regierung und zuhört
und dinge ändert es ist ganz einfach wir
wollen dass die regierung endlich
reagiert und wirklich zuhört so einfach
ist das doch scheint nicht einfach
sondern eher verfahren aktivisten mit
regenschirm und gasmasken gegen
polizeikräfte mit tränengas und
wasserwerfern
brutalität bei festnahmen demolierte
gebäude und fliegende brandsätze allein
heute gab es erneut zahlreiche
festnahmen
die forderung der demonstranten nach
freien wahlen und mehr demokratie
scheint jeden tag unerreichbaren nach
einem überfall auf die armee im
afrikanischen mali ist die zahl der
toten auf mindestens 54 gestiegen
vermutet wird dass islamisten hinter dem
angriff stecken gestern weil die
militärbasis im osten attackiert worden
erst vor einem monat hatten mutmaßliche
islamisten zwei armee stützpunkte
angegriffen
in mali sind auch gut 1000
bundeswehrsoldaten im einsatz um im
auftrag der un das militär auszubilden
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat sich zum
abschluss ihrer indienreise für ein
freihandelsabkommen zwischen dem land
und der eu ausgesprochen
auch werde sich die bundesregierung
dafür einsetzen dass deutsche
unternehmen fachkräfte aus indien
leichter anwerben können
gestern hatten sich beide länder
geeinigt auch in den bereichen
künstliche intelligenz digitalisierung
und klimaschutz stärker
zusammenzuarbeiten
keine entwarnung gibt es in kalifornien
die waldbrände sind immer noch nicht
ganz unter kontrolle
vor allem in der region um los angeles
besteht weiter extreme gefahr denn es
ist sehr trocken und windig insgesamt
haben die flammen sich auf eine fläche
von mehr als 300 quadratkilometern
ausgebreitet
aus den usa berichtet peter jäger nur
noch ein großbrand wütet in kalifornien
der aber ist besonders schwer zu
bekämpfen noch immer ist die erde extrem
trocken die winde wechseln ständig die
richtung das feuer nordwestlich von los
angeles hat bereits 38 quadratkilometer
niedergebrannt etwa 11.000 anwohner
mussten flüchten
ich hatte schafe und ziegen hier für
dich die tore geöffnet habe damit sie
abhauen können
mal sehen ob wir sie später wieder
einfangen werden im nur wenige kilometer
entfernten los angeles stellte sie sich
vors mikrofon für greta tun werk steht
fest grund für die gewaltigen brände ist
der klimawandel
in kalifornien sehen wir gerade diese
feuer hier direkt um die ecke
wir erleben gerade den beginn eines
klimatischen und ökologischen
zusammenbruchs wir dürfen bei dieser
krise nicht weiter weggucken
[Musik]
in der region nördlich von san francisco
können sie dagegen langsam aufatmen
mehrere tage wütete im weinanbaugebiet
sonoma county das sogenannte kincaid
feuer auf einer fläche etwa so groß wie
bremen
viele anwohner haben hier alles verloren
das hier ist von meinem leben übrig 58
jahre alles was ich hatte war das hier
noch kleinigkeiten zu finden ist besser
als nichts
etwa 24 milliarden dollar haben
versicherungen in kalifornien in den
vergangenen zwei jahren für brandschäden
ausgegeben 350.000 weiteren versicherten
haben sie gekündigt und neue policen
angeboten teilweise zum fünffachen preis
der schweizer dramatiker lukas bärfuss
hat die wichtigste literarische
auszeichnung deutschlands bekommen den
georg-büchner-preis geehrt wurde der 47
jährige für seine dramen und romane
bärfuss sagte in seiner dankesrede sein
werk sei in weiten teilen ein zeugnis
für die menschliche niedertracht und
grausamkeit denn aufgabe eines
schriftsteller sei es gewalt zur sprache
zu bringen
und damit sind wir beim fußball und
einer ziemlichen überraschung in der
balance kann man wohl sagen heute
nachmittag das spitzenspiel die
eintracht gegen die bayern
die frankfurter gewannen eindrucksvoll
mit 5 zu 1 die münchner ab der zehnten
minute in unterzahl nach der roten karte
gegen verteidiger jérôme boateng
die bisherigen ergebnisse des zehnten
spieltags dortmund schlägt bayern
entschuldigen stück wolfsburg mit 13 0
leipzig deklassierten mainz mit 18 uhr
leverkusen verliert gegen gladbach 1 2
bremen und freiburg trennten sich
unentschieden 2 2
das abendspiel ist das berliner derby
erstmals in der bundesliga-geschichte
treffen union und hertha aufeinander
bereits gestern gewann hoffenheim gegen
paderborn mit 3 zu 0 die tabelle
gladbach weiterhin erster drei punkte
vorsprung auf den bvb der von platz fünf
auf platz zwei kletterte leipzig dritter
bayern abgerutscht von 24 freiburg
fünfter und frankfurt klettert von platz
9 auf platz 6 die zweite tabellenhälfte
beginnt mit leverkusen und am
tabellenende köln 16 vor augsburg und
paderborn weiterhin mit der roten
laterne als tabellenletzter das
abendspiel in berlin ausführlich zu
sehen bei uns im aktuellen sportstudio
um 23 uhr gast bei dunja hayali dortmund
chef der lizenzspielerabteilung
sebastian kehl südafrika hat sich zum
dritten mal zum rugby weltmeister
gekrönt die springboks setzten sich im
wm-finale gegen die klar favorisierten
engländer durch mit 32 zu zwölf damit
zog südafrika nach titeln mit neuseeland
gleich das bronze holte ob zu hause in
johannesburg oder in der ferne in
yokohama ganz südafrika feiert den neuen
weltmeister
wir spielen nicht nur für uns sondern
für eine ganze nation hatte coach messi
erasmus vor dem spiel gefordert und so
traten seine männer in grün weiß gegen
die favorisierten engländer dann auch
auf in der neuauflage des wm-finales von
2007 waren die screenshots von beginn an
das dominierende team im angriffsspiel
freudig und gewitzt in der defensive
taktisch gut eingestellt zwei
herausragende spielzüge in der
schlussviertelstunde krönten ein
furioses endspiel 32 zu zwölf eine herbe
niederlage für die engländer die sich
die prinz harry am ende aber als fairer
verlierer zeigte
die deutschen hockey damen sind mit dem
erwarteten sieg in die
olympia-qualifikation für tokio 2020
gestartet
im ersten von zwei duellen mit italien
musste sich das team in mönchengladbach
allerdings trotz klarer feldvorteile nur
mit zwei toren begnügen
erleichterung und freude bei den
deutschen hockey-damen nach einem
arbeitssieg in der olympia qualifikation
gegen italien 2 zu 0 heißt es am ende
lange tut sich das deutsche team schwer
vor allem die chancen ausbeutung ist
mangelhaft so bleiben sechs strafecken
vor der pause ungenutzt
erst nach dem seitenwechsel gelingt anna
gabler in der 38 minute der erlösende
treffer zum 1 0
nico lorenz kann in der letzten minute
nach der elften strafecke auf 2 0
erhöhen
morgen können die deutschen im zweiten
spiel gegen italien dann das ticket nach
tokio lösen
das ist am morgen nachmittag und die
herren die treten in der quali gegen
österreich und das wetter morgen am
sonntag wird regnerisch und mel die
details hat gleich gunther tiersch
marietta slomka meldet sich mit dem
heute journal um viertel vor elf wir
danken für ihr interesse und wünschen
ihnen noch ein schönes und unbeschwertes
wochenende auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
mit am live zuschauer zwischen dem regen
wird es morgen kurzzeitig auch mal
sonnig sein weiterhin kommt unser wetter
mehr aus dem südwesten es ist immer noch
mild aber da sind immer wieder diese
dicken wolken pakete dabei die mit dem
regen über deutschland hinwegziehen
heute nacht aber auch morgen früh geht
das eben so weiter und heute nacht fängt
es dann wieder im südwesten an kräftiger
regen
der zieht nach nordosten erreicht morgen
früh berlin hamburg und das münsterland
morgen früh wird es dann auch wieder im
südwesten ein neues regengebiet ankommen
mit kräftigem regen und vorübergehend
wird es auch noch stürmisch hier an der
nordsee für ein paar stunden jetzt am
abend in der nacht lässt der wind dann
wieder nach es bleibt frostfrei und
morgen da haben wir die regengebiete
norddeutschland noch am vormittag so
nordöstlich der elbe
sonst regnet so vom schwarzwald bis zum
thüringer wald zwischendurch kommt die
sonne raus und dann am nachmittag wird
es im norden trocken werden während in
der südhälfte ist doch zeitweise regnet
nur im östlichen bayern nicht da scheint
zeitweise die sonne und den alpen haben
wir anfangs auch diesen starken föhn der
wind weht frisch aus dem süden und es
wird fast so warm wie heute
meist sind es etwa 12 bis 15 grad aber
heute hatten wir im südwesten bis zu 20
die werden nicht mehr erreicht und in
den nächsten tagen bleibt es dann
wechselhaft in der neuen woche und es
wird dann langsam bis zum mittwoch auch
etwas kühler
ich wünsche noch einen schönen abend und
das ist gut